hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
know where the moonpool blueprint is and
where it is is where I kind of suspected
it would be in the first place but there
was a giant sea monster in the way so
now what I have to do is I have to
venture towards the ship and I have two
options I could either take I have three
really I could take the long way around
the front of the ship or I could take
the long way around the back of the ship
or I could kind of sprint through the
monster and hope for the best that
doesn't seem like the best option but
you know it's kind of the only option
that I have as a direct route though
fourth option I ride Sancho and tell him
to fight the guy and hope for the best
that they manage to blow each other up
in a gigantic Godzilla style fight I'm
not sure what are the odds of that are
happening actually I don't even know
what I'm supposed to be able to do with
those big guys because I don't think
that I'm supposed to be able to kill
them unless they have some very special
meat that I need but that's besides the
point because I have to hit this head-on
I have to be brave and I'm anti brave oh
is that oh that's him okay so he's over
there which is fine 100% a ok with that
he does not know I'm here but what I do
need it I need a little bit of water so
Oh are there two Oh No
there's more than one please tell me
this ocean isn't just infested with
these a-holes I mean nice people fish
monsters whatever you want to call them
they're adorable whatever they may be oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh this is bad
well this is hundreds of bad
okay we're fine I think 100% maybe I do
need some water
so I'm hoping I can pop one of these bad
boys open get some water out of it but
yet it doesn't help me very much but
I'll take it
okay so I don't hear the roars anymore
Oh scheisse damn it oh crap
what's the flash Lydia damn it stop
uh-huh why did it unite how the hell did
it get night already there we go oh that
doesn't draw attention to me in any way
oh no I'm kind of screwed oh boy what
does that set a fragment is it fragment
that might be a fragment where is it
where is it where is it it was right
here
there's seamoth that doesn't help me at
all that's exactly not what I needed
okay but there's got to be other stuff
what is these things are these actual
usable things and let me get a good look
at these huh it could be something here
whoa Cyclops hull fragment can i huh
okay what does that mean Cyclops hull
does that for an upgrade Cyclops engine
is that for also an upgrade there's this
there was another update made to the
game something in the darkness hi oh god
oh god oh god again huh get in oh Jesus
what the hell happened there oh man
someone got angry and tossed and crap
around okay but I think I'm in generally
the right area so if I can get some more
fragments I should get what I need it's
like a bonanza of parts why did it all
drift over here now seamoth I don't need
the seamoth fragment I need the seamoth
upgrader the moonpool they said it was
over here it's a whole bunch of
that doesn't sound good it's on same tie
good C Mon damn it
okay god dammit are all these just C
moths it's kind of hard to tell where
everything is in the dark oh that I good
all that I'd done uh okay I think we're
okay there's the ship I'm on the
opposite side Oh is it baby oh god oh
god that's not good oh that's not good
oh that's not good
oh that's not good Oh we're boned or
bone or owned hello friendlies better be
friendly
there's tons of fragments around here
still fall on me seems okay I'm gonna
test the waters literally seamoth
seamoth is nothing but seamoth fragments
there was another update to the game
that added underwater farming so there's
a thing if I ever needed an unlimited
food spa can't be can't still be after
me there's no way oh hey buddy I don't
care about you chunk you lost a tooth
Maroun but what I do need is water else
I'm just gonna die shut up I'm busy with
some they said and by they I mean the
collective internet said they said that
it was over here damn it
okay what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
leave or I'm not gonna leave I'm going
to you know fast-forward for you guys
I'm gonna go out and I'm gonna explore
farther out into these reaches hello rot
Rome uh-oh
death incoming from severe dehydration I
should have been going back towards home
but I think I know where the moon pool
is whew I think I'm in the right area to
do bad I'm gonna die here and then
probably my fee mouth is gonna be thick
here but this is new
and I Lou what's here I know what's
hidden in the blue pod pool and shall be
mine
Thanks where the hell am i oh I'm in my
thingamabob er I'm gonna ride the USS
[ __ ] the ocean straight into this zone
because I am the captain here and I will
not be a Swedish hope I'm going the
right way I think I was not entirely
sure oh well now that's what I call
captaining music glorious ready for my
takeover of this entire ocean so my
biggest problem was that I actually went
the wrong way as opposed I want every
single direction that I could have
possibly gone without hitting my actual
target which is a problem cuz I'm stupid
ah the USS [ __ ] the ocean is slow as
balls at least once I get out of here
maybe I could use it as like a landmark
or something I need to find I need to
get out and navigate I don't have a
first mate to tell me exactly where I is
oh this [ __ ] better be the o sea mouth
over there it'll tell me oh I'm too far
god damn it USS [ __ ] the ocean you led
me astray I thought I could trust you
turns out I can't trust nobody brothers
do port bow that way over there
do that thing there it is it didn't show
my seamoth before I'm show now finally
we're gonna do this we're gonna get Ben
we're gonna get this moon pool cuz I
know for a fact ah that this is where
it's supposed to be and also there might
be other blueprints down there and a
nine minutes to put I managed to pull up
a map of this I managed to pull up a map
there's a map now I know where I'm going
kind of a little bit not really oh well
the USS [ __ ] the ocean will remain above
so that they can keep an eye on the
situation but there's something over
here who is in a fragment Austin cannon
well that sounds pretty cool
whoo I got the propulsion cannon I
didn't I didn't know if I had that
already I'm gonna gather up some some
fishy fishies whoa what's Regin ratchet
Holden I picked up Reginald oh I'm sorry
that seems highly inappropriate I'm a
gentleman and a scholar I didn't mean to
pick up any other gentlemen that were
swimming in the sea actually I keep
doing it see I say one thing and then I
do completely differently because I'm
actually an [ __ ]
there we go that's what I'm looking for
okay so this is good this good start was
that lumen amok side crystal that sounds
cool
I want a lot of those wait whoa I picked
up a diamond cool what are those are
they alive I hope not cuz that spells
doom for me Gold is tons of it it is
good good good good good
ah hurry up why is it all the way up
there yeah okay captain thank you Karen
oh how I have missed you I hope you
didn't think that I abandoned you out
here in the whatever the place we are at
is the thing but I was told that there's
something down in what are you what the
hell is
well what has that ah it's gross
oh it's bulbous oh it's got a minor
ecosystem inside of it Oh what are you
what are you membrane tree oh that's a
good name
I'm glad it's that not something timed
and nice okay glad I scan that come here
bladder fish need you Wow
I found it oh boy transfuser I don't
even know what that is but I wanted oh
cool
we're doing great oh we're doing so good
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy we got some
things oh boy oh boy okay so I just got
to find the rest of it and we're good
this is spooky I do appreciate like the
artistic miss of all this that's so cool
it's so cool just like these specks of
blue scattered across them got it I'll
stop I'm at 16% what a load of ass go
out be a hand Oh cuz I see some things
down there they better be what I need
come on baby yes Oh oh it's moonpool yes
yes and a transfuser that'll be the last
one in the transfuser - yes okay we're
doing okay shockingly we're doing
acceptable we're doing barely good so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna make
my way back home and then I'm gonna make
this thing do the upgrades and get on
with this game in excellent fashion so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I know I know I keep going out and just
saying I'm gonna do things that I'm not
gonna do it but I've been playing for
about 30 minutes so I'm gonna get to
this in the next video which is gonna
come very soon so thanks again everybody
so much for watching thank you for your
patience with me because I am slow but
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video dad maybe I'll
learn someday